researchers have discovered that at
least one shark species tends towards
vegetarianism the meter-long bonnethead
shark which sticks close to shore and
hunts in shallow water usually feasts on
shrimp small crabs and fish found in
seagrass meadows however researchers
realize that juvenile bonnethead
stomachs could contain more sea grass
than critters so a graduate student fed
several sharks a diet of 90% eel grass
and 10% squid despite this mostly
vegetarian fare all the Sharks gained
weight they were digesting at least half
the seagrass they were eating that's on
par with juvenile sea turtles which are
well-known to rely on eating sea grass
this is a bit puzzling because the
bonnethead has the same shortcut as its
Hammerhead relatives and usually plant
eaters evolved longer guts so
researchers suspect that microbes in the
bonnethead shark are doing the digesting
for it no other sharks are known to eat
plants though whale sharks hunt
microscopic animals floating in the
water and may also consume some
microscopic plants but it's not clear if
they're digesting those plants because
seagrass meadows are so important for
filtering water removing carbon dioxide
from the air adding lots of oxygen
instead understanding the role of these
sharks in these Meadows is very
important
you
[Music]
[Music]